- Ah, well, Gloria's not
the only single parent
in the house.
I am, and so as everyone in our audience,
I salute all of you.
(audience cheering and applauding)
It's not an easy task,
and that's why this hour
we're gonna celebrate
what we pull off every day.
I think we can all agree raising kids
in a two parent home is no easy task,
but doing it on your own requires
a special kind of strength
and patience and lots of prayer.
Our first guest is also a single parent.
She's the cohost of the
"Two Funny Mamas" podcast,
as well as a Weight Watchers ambassador.
Give it up for our friend Kym Whitley
(audience cheers)
(soft upbeat music)
(audience applauding)
Single parents in the audience.
And you adopted as well.
- I did.
He was four days old
and it changed my life.
And people always say, oh, you saved him,
I was like, no, he saved me
because I was about to be a stripper.
(Kelly and audience laughing)
- Making money where you can.
- You got to do what you got to do.
- Well, we have a house full
of single moms and dads,
and a few of them would love to share
what they're going through
so we can weigh in.
I don't know if you want me to weigh in,
but let's get to it.
So where's Deseret?
- Right here.
- Hi Deseret.
- Hi.
(audience applauding)
Hi Kelly, nice to meet you.
- [Kelly] Hi.
- I have two kids and I've been
a single mom since day one.
They're amazing children,
but my brother always tells
me that I reward bad behavior.
For example, if we're at a store
and they're like fussing around
and they tell me to buy them something
and I just kind of give
in and buy it for them
'cause I just don't want
to deal with it anymore.
And I feel like I'm too soft
and I have a hard time disciplining them.
And I just...
- We're so different Deseret.
- Oh my God.
- They're about to be
pre-teen so I need help,
like breaking this cycle
and bringing some balance back to my life.
- Oh my God, that cycle is going.
- It's gone.
The cycle is gone.
- They are taking advantage of me.
- Here's the thing
I will relate to and
I think everybody can,
sometimes they just wear you down.
You're just like,
I'm just tired of having
this conversation.
You're just, you're exhausted.
You're like, I cannot
believe you're surprised
that bedtime happens every night.
Like, why are we having this argument?
And it wears you down.
So I get why you kind of give in,
but I will tell you what.
Literally my kids the other day,
they were fighting over something
'cause they do that thing where,
there's is a little different.
Like they know that if we go to a store,
I prep them.
I say, we're going in this store
and you're not getting anything.
We're doing something for
somebody else or whatever.
Or I prep them and say, hey,
if y'all want to grab
something like little,
you get one little thing or something,
but I am big on prepping
them because if you don't,
that's when the nightmare happens.
And also they were fighting
the other day over something
and they were so entitled.
I mean, y'all have so many toys.
And so I took that toy
straight to the trash.
- That's what I'm talking about.
- I was like, I'm sorry.
Since neither one of you
knows how to share it,
we will give it to the garbage.
And it's gone.
- Until they go in the
garbage and get it out.
- Oh, they won't go in the garbage.
They hate that I make
them take the trash out.
- Oh, God.
Joshua has pulled out many
toys from the garbage.
- Oh, really?
- I threw his iPad away one day,
oh, I went and got that out.
(audience laughing)
But I had to teach him a lesson.
He was crying, oh my God, oh my God.
As soon as he went to bed, I was like,
don't let me forget that iPad.
- That was $700.
- Exactly.
But you have to, I think,
you know, especially,
I mean, they're preteen.
You haven't missed the window,
but now you're gonna have
to probably attack it
a little differently because
I had the same problem,
but you have to start
as early as possible.
For anyone else that is
listening, you know that,
especially if they go in a store,
for people with kids that have a tantrum,
my child has had a tantrum in the store
and I had one right with him.
- Everybody has,
that's like when we go to
Disneyland and you see,
like Disney, I feel like theme parks
are the place you see
most families just broken
on the ground.
Like this is supposed to
be the happiest place ever
and they're just like God, I wanna leave.
Like everybody in here just like,
oh, I feel at home,
everybody's the same army.
- It's so funny.
And I love when you see
the parents just walking
and the kids are screaming behind them.
(Kym imitating a crying child)
And the parents are just walking.
So what do you want to eat?
I don't know.
(audience applauding)
- That's a good one though.
We all have problems.
- Thank you.
- Where's Tony?
Hi Tony.
- Right here.
(audience clapping)
Hi Kelly.
I'm a single dad of a 13 year old daughter
and she is amazing.
I love her to death.
When she was younger, our
relationship was awesome.
We did everything together,
vacations cruises,
homework time, everything.
She was a daddy's girl, 100% daddy's girl,
but she's a teenager now.
And things are getting a little tricky.
And I have been a single
dad for five years now.
And I mean, single, single,
like not even one date in five years.
And yeah, exactly.
But I'm ready now.
I think I'm ready to start dating again.
- Oh, to have the
conversation with her now?
- Yes and so that's what I'm here for.
I want her to know that she's still
the number one girl in my
life and will always be,
but how do I go about
having that conversation
where daddy's on Bumble now.
(audience laughing)
- Daddy's on Bumble.
- I love that.
(audience clapping)
- That's hard.
How do you do that?
- Tony's tripping, Tony's tripping.
So Tony look, what's your daughter's name?
- Ava.
- Get Ava tonight, bring her over.
We're gonna go to dinner,
Ava's gonna be with me.
You're gonna be like, this is Kym,
we're just going out to dinner.
I'm gonna reach over and
rub your hand a little bit.
She's gonna freak out.
(audience applauding)
- I'm holding you to that.
I'm holding you to that.
- Oh my God.
- I feel like I gotta do
some charity, five years.
I got you.
- Five years.
- Oh my God.
- I got to tell you though, I don't know,
I feel like that's,
I'm still where you were years ago.
So I don't have to worry about that yet,
but I feel like as long
as you still show her
that she's, you know, with your actions,
that she's still number one priority.
I think that's the thing, right?
But she's got to know
that you have a life,
like she's got to know that you...
- You know Ava is in her room at night,
hey, is your mother single?
Somebody get my daddy a girlfriend.
Are you kidding me?
- Not all kids.
Some kids get freaked out.
- But that's why he has to
start bringing women around.
- Well, not a lot.
- I don't know these days.
Just bring a man or woman,
somebody around, okay,
that you're dating or who
want to date a potential
because they have to see the
interaction that it eases in.
Because I learned this from Nia Long,
because I had an argument with her
when my son was first born,
she was saying that you should introduce
the person you're dating early.
And I said, no, absolutely not.
I have to wait until he's older
and then I'll bring them
around once I know (indistinct)
She said, no, you bring them
around as friends first.
So it won't be foreign.
I saw her the other night,
we're doing a movie together.
And I saw her and I apologized.
I started a little Twitter argument.
I said, you were absolutely right.
So what I do is bring
men around with my son,
introduced as a friend
so there's, you know,
he just sees that, you know,
mommy has male friends.
Now I can tell if we're gonna go further,
then maybe we'll do some
family things together
and it'll go deeper and it
won't be a surprise to him.
Also, kids are very
good at seeing red flags
because my child would say,
mommy, you know he smokes weed.
(audience laughing)
- Please tell me your
response is, so does mommy.
(audience laughing)
- Oh my God.
I can't take you.
- That would be the greatest response.
- Could you imagine.
And so does mommy.
- It's gonna be all right.
- Oh, that would be horrible.
- Oh my God.
- That's a hard one though.
That is a hard one.
But I think five years, you've
put in enough time, man.
It's your turn.
(audience clapping)
Thanks Tony, good luck.
Let's move on to Johara.
(audience clapping)
Hi Johara.
- How's it going?
- What a cool name first of all.
- Appreciate it, appreciate it.
- Yeah, so what's going on
in your single parent world?
- So I am a single dad to
a beautiful and creative,
nearly 10 year old, right?
Sometimes she'll spend
time with me out here,
but she lives in Louisiana
with her mom and her family.
But I do my best to keep
in contact with her,
call her on the phone, FaceTime
her and things like that.
So now she's at the age where,
puberty is starting to hit
and I'm kinda not ready for that.
- Yeah, good luck, yeah.
- So I want to have that
conversation with her,
but you know, it's kind of awkward.
How do I go about having
that conversation with her
without making it weird?
- Oh, wow.
First of all, next time she comes out,
I got a 10 year old too.
I'm just saying.
I mean, you're single, I'm single.
(audience laughing)
Hey, I'm just trying to help the cause.
For me, I felt like this,
my mom and dad gave me a book.
I'm telling you, they gave me
a book and said, good luck.
- Oh my gosh.
- Yeah, that was at the time that parents
were pretty nervous about
talking about the birds and bees.
I don't know about you,
they weren't comfortable.
But let me tell you something,
if she's 10 years old, we got
Instagram, we got Facebook.
We got all these, your
child knows a lot more.
And the kids are talking in
school, there's television,
you know, just TV alone,
she knows a lot more.
So it can't be uncomfortable.
You have to be honest and real.
But you can't start talking,
you have to let her ask questions.
That's the first thing.
- Yeah.
I think because maybe, yeah, my mom,
she's so conservative.
We're so opposite.
I'm very talkative and she's not.
And she wasn't ever really talking to me
about stuff like that
and I think that was just
her generation or whatever.
But for me, like and my
sister, like we're very open.
Like even if my nephew
has asked her stuff,
who's like a 19 year old grown man now,
like we're very open.
I feel like once you make it awkward,
if you make it awkward,
it becomes awkward.
But a lot of that's just
natural, it's just nature.
It's just like science.
and it's one of the things I feel like
if you make it the red
button, it's awkward.
But it's hard because
they are way advanced
because of like, they
started talking about stuff
and I was like, oh my God,
I'm acting like it's normal, I'm sweating.
Because I don't want it to be awkward,
but it's amazing how much they know at 10.
- They really do.
It's embarrassing and it's scary.
So I think you just have to wait
for her to start asking questions.
- Yeah, I think so too, yeah.
And honestly too, like her mom
had talked to her a little
bit about stuff like that too?
- Absolutely, absolutely.
Both of us do have an open
communication with her.
So she's very open and
willing to ask questions.
But right now she's just
focusing on roadblocks
and I wish he could do that
for the rest of her life.
- No, you don't want that.
Because you want her to ask
because she will find out in the streets.
- Yeah.
Or on a school bus,
that's where I found out.
And it was a weird way to
find out, I'll tell you that.
There's a lot of stuff that
happens on a school bus.
- Absolutely.
- And you're like, wait, what?